When NBC decided to create a spinoff from
their hit series The Blacklist, they had the
perfect star in mind to headline the series:
Famke Janssen.
After making her debut in the show's third
season, her character Susan Hargrave became
the focus of The Blacklist: Redemption.
If you think you recognize her from somewhere,
it's probably because you've seen Janssen
in one of her dozens of film and television
roles.
Here's why Susan from The Blacklist looks
so familiar.
GoldenEye
Janssen got her start as a model in the late
'80s, but in the early '90s she decided to
transition to acting.
She soon landed small roles on shows like
Star Trek: The Next Generation and in films
such as Fathers & Sons.
But her big break came in the 1995 James Bond
film GoldenEye, where she played the sinister
Russian agent Xenia Onatopp.
"Xenia Sergeyevna Onatopp."
"Onatopp?"
"Onatopp."
The character has become a fan favorite, consistently
ranking among the best Bond Girls ever.
House on Haunted Hill
Following the success of GoldenEye, Janssen
was offered a number of roles.
One of the most high profile was opposite
Geoffrey Rush as one half of the eccentric
couple running the show in the 1999 horror
remake House on Haunted Hill.
The flick was a critical punching bag, but
has become a bit of a cult favorite anyway.
X-Men
No matter what Janssen does in her career,
there are many fans who will always see her
as Jean Grey from 20th Century Fox's X-Men
franchise.
Since 2000, Janssen has played the red-haired
mutant psychic multiple times, including the
original X-Men, X2: X-Men United in 2003,
and X-Men: The Last Stand in 2006, where she
was killed off.
She later appeared in 2013's The Wolverine
as a figment of Logan's tortured imagination,
but thanks to some time travel shenanigans,
she was returned to life for realsies in 2014's
X-Men: Days of Future Past.
Nip/Tuck
A year after X2 hit theaters, Janssen landed
a recurring role in the second season of FX's
medical drama Nip/Tuck.
The primary antagonist of that season, transgender
life coach Ava Moore became a key recurring
character, returning in season six for a major
arc.
Hide and Seek
One of Janssen's stranger roles was in the
psychological thriller Hide and Seek, where
she played opposite Robert DeNiro.
Her part as family friend Dr. Katherine Carson
wasn't large, but she figured prominently
in each of the film's five different endings.
And you thought the X-Men movies were hard
to keep straight…
Taken
Twentieth Century Fox apparently didn't want
to let go of Janssen following the original
X-Men trilogy's conclusion, so they cast her
as Lenore "Lenny" Mills in their Taken series.
In 2008, she played the wife of Liam Neeson's
Bryan Mills, whose daughter is taken captive.
Bad move, fools.
"I have a very particular set of skills.
Skills I have acquired over a very long career.
Skills that make me a nightmare for people
like you."
In 2012, she returned in a larger role, this
time as the victim of a revenge kidnapping.
Neeson, of course, saves her.
Too bad he couldn't get the job done in 2015's
Taken 3, where it's her life that gets taken
at the start of the film.
One of these days, one of Janssen's characters
will actually survive a trilogy.
Hansel & Gretel: Witch Hunters
In-between Taken installments, Janssen starred
as the sinister grand witch Muriel in 2013's
Hansel & Gretel: Witch Hunters, a re-imagining
of the classic fairy tale.
The film wasn't exactly a critical favorite,
but it did well enough at the box office to
warrant a sequel.
Whether or not Janssen will be involved hasn't
been announced yet.
Even though her character died, don't count
her out.
Hemlock Grove
In 2013, Janssen shifted away from movies
and back into television in a big way, starring
in a leading role in the groundbreaking Netflix
series Hemlock Grove, which was one of the
first digitally streamed shows to ever receive
an Emmy nomination.
She played Olivia Godfrey, head of the sinister
Godfrey Institute for Biomedical Technologies,
for all three seasons before the show ended
in 2015.
Yuck.
How to Get Away with Murder
Before landing the lead in The Blacklist:
Redemption, Janssen took another juicy role
in the hit series How to Get Away with Murder,
playing attorney Eve Rothlow, a former friend
and lover of Viola Davis's lead character,
Annalise Keating.
Still smarting from their breakup years ago,
Eve finally got over Annalise in season three,
and walked away.
Whether or not she ever returns may depend
on how long The Blacklist: Redemption stays
on the air.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!